hey hello everybody and welcome to
another moneymaking guide today I'm
going to be going over the top five
level three moneymaking methods and by
this I mean literally you can do a level
three you need no skill requirements for
some of them you will need money but I
have tried to focus on those that don't
require very much because I know if
you're level three mower often than not
you're not going to have a lot of cash
um so yeah let's get started so at
number five is uh kind of an unusual
method uh and it makes about 200 uh 210k
an hour like that uh no experience
gained as will the case be for a lot of
these methods uh because there's no
requirement usually it doesn't involve a
skill at all uh because almost always
you'll need the skill to be above level
one um but yeah so what we're going to
be doing is creating banana baskets uh
ignore everything else here this isn't
part of the video but all you have to do
is uh spell banana right and then put it
um into the basket so we're going to buy
some bananas first uh 55 whatever it's
not a huge deal about getting the
perfect price
um I don't know we'll do 300 bananas and
that will need um five bananas per
basket so we'll need 60 baskets um and
yeah so then you just go and buy the
baskets they're Dirt Cheap uh everything
about this method is really cheap
obviously you do need a little bit of
money but honestly it's not that much
like uh to do this for probably an hour
you'll need maybe 500k or something like
that nothing too strenuous so we'll go
ahead claim the bananas and claim the
baskets uh now the way I do this is I do
four baskets at a time uh just because
if you do five uh it'll you'll make a
banana basket three because it doesn't
quite fit all in your inventory uh so
deposit those deposit those so what you
have to do is withdraw four baskets and
a bunch of bananas and then all you have
to do is Spam click them into the
baskets and you make about 100 150 GP on
each basket of course the prices uh can
vary quite a bit um but yeah we'll do
these s your baskets and see how long it
takes okay so it actually didn't take
very long for the bananas to get into
the baskets under made that a little bit
but if we go ahead and uh divide it by
how much time it took which is only 105
seconds it gives us about uh basket
every 2 seconds uh multiply that by 3600
for an hour and we're going to get about
2,000 let's just say 2,000 baskets uh
you could do in an hour uh so we have a
look at what we sold it for we sold them
for
23880 and if we take off the cost of the
ingredients - 120 -
159900 gives us about
7860 again we's divide that by into the
second so 74 GP a second uh time 3600
it's going to be about uh well actually
up to 270k so of course it varies but
I'd say this is between 200 and 300K an
hour very good for not having a high
requirement or any requirement you don't
need very much money at all either uh
the only negative side to this is um the
amount of bananas you're going to need
you're going to need like 10,000 bananas
an hour uh so you may have to buy those
in advance as well as selling off the
baskets could take a while another
option for this is to go ahead and just
fill the ban the baskets with bananas
and to do that you just have to go to
kja bring some baskets and fill them up
with bananas not as good but also an
option okay coming in at number four is
going to be uh grinding desert goat
horns uh another kind of unusual method
but I just tested it out and it works
pretty well uh for having almost no
requirements uh the materials are a
little bit more expensive but still not
that bad
uh you can expect to do four to 5,000 of
these an hour and there's a little bit
of a difference depending on if you want
to do this very AFK like or as quickly
as possible uh so we deposit all the
desert goat horns you're going to need a
pestl and mortar and goat horns uh so
there's a couple uh two ways you can do
this either you can just click and uh
it'll slowly grind them all uh takes
longer though or you can go in the very
bottom and do something like this a lot
quicker but um obviously a lot more
click intensive
probably recommended to do this because
it's going to be substantially quicker
so I'm going to be doing this and yeah
we'll go ahead and time it takes to do
300 okay so grinding all those go horns
took about uh 4 minutes actually right
on the dot and we sold them all for
163 uh so our total profit is going to
be
49200 is what we sold them for minus 30
300 so we made about 18 or 19k in 4
minutes uh divide by 4 4 times by 60
we're going to get about
283k uh these often go for cheaper I
mean the prerequisite item the desert
goat horn will often go about for like
83 uh so you can probably get up to 300
350k an hour doing this uh the items
actually buy pretty quickly the thing I
don't like about it is how click
intensitive it is uh if you go ahead and
just wait for them to make uh
automatically you're cutting your profit
in half if not in a third so it's
definitely not worth doing it at that
point so just prepared to click quite a
bit all right coming in at number three
is going to be crushing birds nests uh
they buy pretty quickly on the gr
exchange the main drawback to this
method is they are expensive uh one of
the most expensive method I'm going to
be showing you each bird's nest is about
four or 5K uh so you have to do this
sparingly if you have a lot of money of
course you can buy a lot of these in
advance uh but be aware of the uh buying
limit for this is also just 1,000 uh so
it's a little limiting that way but I
thought I'd throw it in because it is a
pretty good method uh doesn't actually
require anything same deal for how you
did the crushed horns you're just going
to crush them with a pestil and mortar
pretty sure the crush speed should be
the same uh so no differen is there if
we withdraw all the birds
nest and go ahead and you can crush him
automatically just like the original one
uh but again not going to be worth it
cuz you can see how slow it is uh more
recommended to just Spam click
fortunately the uh Sprite is not that
that that different so it's a little
hard to tell when you're done uh but
same speed so you should be able to do
around 5,000 of these in an hour of
course that's not super likely you'll
have to go ahead and buy them in advance
um but yeah we'll go ahead and Crush
these three into Birds Nest and see how
much we make okay so there we go we've
sold off all the crush nest for 4167 or
1250k in total uh so we'll go ahead and
have a look at our history here so
1250 uh minus 127 gives us uh 33 K uh in
the 4 minutes it took I decd it was
around 4 minutes uh not exactly the same
but I decided to use the same time frame
as the last method just because it makes
a little more sense that way uh so 4
minutes divide that by four so we're
making about 8.25k a minute time 60
actually gives us nearly 500k so this
actually worked out quite a bit better
than I had originally thought uh so
actually good money per hour for no
requirement drawbacks are only a 1,000
buying limit I believe every 4 hours and
uh it's expensive
okay and coming in at number two is
going to be collecting white berries now
I think right now the money per hour
might be similar to the last method but
this one is a lot more consistent
doesn't require any starting cache uh
and I think it's overall just a stronger
method even if the GP per hour sometimes
might dip below some of the other ones
uh but yeah so all you're going to need
for this is a cut weapon or a knife I'm
using the iron simitar that being said I
think the m simitar is actually uh
weighs less so it's preferable to bring
that but we are theoretically doing it
as a level three wood higher agility is
always nice but you don't need anything
like I said uh so what we're going to do
is come to Edgeville and pull this lever
here uh which will teleport you right
away into the deep Wilderness um in my
inventory you see I have some energy
potions uh that's just to get there
quicker and some food uh you're not
going to be risking anything so it's not
a big deal if you die but uh the main
thing and the main reason you do not
want to die is um the Looting bag uh now
to get the loot loting bag you'll have
to kill any monster in the wilderness
you can kill level three rats in like
level one Wilderness so it's easy to do
at level three uh but you don't really
want to die with it because you won't
get it back I'm just going to hop world
cuz there's somebody here just in case
and that's okay see you later um but
yeah so if you die you do lose the
Looting bag which can take a little
while to get back it's not too timec
consuming but it's a one in 20 or one in
30 drop rate so it's it's not
insignificant one important thing worth
noting is uh you do want your HP to be
as high as possible you can do this with
10 HP but uh it's going to result in you
dying a lot more cuz the lava dragons do
hit quite a bit even with your anti-fire
Shield equipped you can Juke them out if
you really want to but it's a lot
riskier so you can see I might get
through here without taking a hit but
where you need to go is down here and uh
you will probably get hit by at least
one lava
dragon uh yeah I got hit 14 uh so yeah
basically where we have to come here is
right by the white berries so that's
what the food's important for and all
you do is you pick up the white berries
they respawn in like 3 seconds watch out
for p i mean they'll probably come and
kill you even though you don't have
anything to lose uh but yeah still be
mindful of them so yeah pick up the
white berries and then just wait 3
seconds as you get them fill up your
loading bag and that's about it so we'll
do an inventory and I've been timing it
and we'll see how long it takes okay so
we finished the run and ended up getting
52 White berries in about 7 Minutes uh
and didn't die luckily now uh we sold
them for
48.8k and that took about 7
minutes so about uh 7K per minute and
per hour we're looking at about
420k uh this can go up to 500k 600k if
the price of white berries are higher
but right now it's about
420k per hour uh which is still pretty
good for having no requirements uh the
only downside of this method is you can
die both to pkers and to uh the dragons
so just beware and last up of course is
going to be the most easy accessible uh
early game Money Maker which is tanning
dragy I know most people know about it
but it is honestly just really good for
no risk the only thing you really need
is a bit of money to start with uh but
even tanion the string Dragon height is
only about 600k and now it is important
to have a look at all the different
types and have a look at the margins uh
right now it looks like blue dragon hide
is a lot better looks like 100 or 250 GP
on each one uh which will translate to
about 75k after doing all of these uh
and it shouldn't really take that long
to tan 300 leather uh another thing you
should probably bring with you is weight
reducing equipment I believe you don't
have that uh stamina and some energy
potions so we'll go to alarid and go
ahead and T all of them okay so I'm done
and it took about 6 minutes on the dot
to tan 300 leathers and we sold them all
for
2248 uh which is 674k and we bought them
64k pretty
well so that leaves us with 70k minus uh
6K for tanning the leather and uh about
9k for the stamina potion uh leaves us
with about 55k in about 6 minutes time
60 is going to be about 550k in profit I
I think it's still worth using stamina
potions uh cuz you can get a lot more
done in a shorter amount of time uh you
can see how even a simple method like
this can be profitable uh even if you
only have a mill uh you can go ahead buy
uh 500 of these 10 them sell them and
then just redo it it's not too hard so
yeah those are my top five money-making
methods that can be done at level three
hope you guys enjoyed uh don't forget to
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already don't mention that enough
anymore and uh thanks for watching guys
[Music]